breaking news now the latest daily
statistics for covert 19
in the uk have been released 62
322 new confirmed cases of coronavirus
have been
recorded in the uk in the past 24 hours
that is up from 60
916 yesterday
1041 further deaths within 28 days of a
positive coronavirus test
have been recorded and that is up from
830
yesterday let's bring in skies ashna
haranag
who is in the newsroom we heard from the
government's
chief scientist chief medical officer
chief scientific advisor yesterday both
warning us
that the figures were going to get worse
and they certainly have done ashna
they really have i think what's really
concerning is that these figures are
showing
no signs of slowing down in the last two
weeks of december
the cases of covert 19 rose by 70
and the headline figure that's come from
today's uh
announcement and drop of data is that
this is the highest number of deaths
that we have seen
since the 21st of april during the peak
of the first wave of the covert 19
pandemic
let's take a look at what they look like
though 1041
coronavirus deaths were recorded in the
uk in the last
24 hours uh that means
that brings the total number of people
who have died in the uk within 28 days
of a positive test to 77
346. 62
322 new cases of coven 19
have also been recorded in the uk for a
number of days now the figure for the
number of people who have died from
covert 19 has surpassed
800 yesterday we saw um
the number of people testing positive um
that was the ninth day that that figure
had been over fifty thousand
today is the second day the number of
people testing positive for covert 19
is says surpass 60 000 in a 24
hour period yesterday as you mentioned
there we heard from the chief
medical officer professor chris witte
and he pleaded with us almost didn't he
that we
need to take things seriously public
compliance has never been so important
and crucially those figures are going to
rise and at the moment they are already
extraordinarily high
and to have that figure today of the
number of deaths surpassing what we have
seen in april that is a really stark
reminder of the position that we are in
and yes these figures are frightening
and they make for very somber news but
there is hope in all of this
which is different the first time round
we have a vaccine
a couple of vaccines maybe even three
soon and the
the likelihood of those being injected
into our arms is increasingly becoming
uh more like the light at the end of the
tunnel as it has been so
um aptly named the crucial thing with
all of this is that as soon as we can
get those
vulnerable people vaccinated the sooner
these figures will start to go down